[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages sur Public Sénat avec nos
experts on prend du recul et du temps
pour donner du sens à l'actualité et
justement ce soir on aurait pu le titrer
notre premier débat on y comprend plus
rien que ce soit sur les carrières
longues ou la retraite minimum à 1200
euros les dernières annonces du
gouvernement ajoute une dose de
confusion qui devrait être alimenter le
rejet du texte par une majorité de
Français on va essayer d'y voir plus
clair dans une minute et puis pour notre
débat de société volontairement décalé
vous le savez de l'actualité du jour
c'est un fléau sans fin que l'on va
analyser celui du harcèlement scolaire
qui pousse certains enfants au suicide
le 7 janvier dernier c'était Lucas 13
ans qui ne supportait plus les insultes
homophobes subies dans la cour et sur
les réseaux sociaux Séverine sa maman ne
réclame pas forcément de lourdes
sanctions contre les harceleurs
j'imagine aucune peine pour un adulte
c'est un gamin donc voilà je veux que
ça le fasse ça l'efface réfléchir que il
recommence pas et puis qui mène des
actions peut-être derrière et peut-être
que ça va les faire évoluer et qui mène
des actions derrière
que pouvons-nous faire collectivement
pour mieux protéger nos enfants quels
sont les signes les premiers signes du
harcèlement on répond entre autres à ces
questions dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
les dernières tractations les annonces
de la première ministre et les
interrogations qui vont avec une journée
résumée par Jonathan Dupriez
Elisabeth borne a une nouvelle fois
cédée à la droite devant les députés
hier la locataire de Matignon a fait un
geste sur les carrières longues
désormais les personnes qui ont commencé
à travailler avant 21 ans si elles ont
atteint l'âge de départ anticipé requis
devront cotiser 43 ans au lieu de 44
dans le projet initial du gouvernement
j'ai pris un engagement et il donne eu
lieu à un amendement du Gouvernement
déposé aujourd'hui qui pose le principe
que dès lors que qui est atteint l'âge
de départ anticipé la réforme ne prévoit
pas pour les carrières longues de durée
de cotisation supérieure à 43 ans mais
cette annonce mal comprise a fait
l'objet de plusieurs précisions de
Matignon par la suite donnant une
impression d'impréparation du
gouvernement obligé de se justifier
devant la presse non
c'est pas fait à la va-vite clairement
non nous adaptons nous faisons évoluer
le texte nous écoutons alors c'est
peut-être une habituel malgré cette
nouvelle concession faite au Républicain
dont les voix sont essentielles pour
voter l'ensemble de la réforme LR a
tourné le dos à la majorité
macronistique et au Palais Bourbon en
rejetant aux côtés de la nuque et du RN
l'article 2 du texte sur l'index seniors
un revers de taille pour l'exécutif qui
compte désormais sur le Sénat pour
rétablir cette index visant à mesurer le
taux d'emploi des seniors dans les
entreprises mais la droite sénatoriale
n'en veut pas à ce stade il y a un sujet
Seigneur est pas forcément index nous
avions déjà travaillé au Sénat là-dessus
on a commis un rapport sur le travail
des seniors et nous avons d'autres
propositions donc on va les étudier par
rapport à cette position de suppression
de l'index mais avant que le texte
n'arrive au Sénat le 2 mars le
gouvernement très en difficulté à
l'Assemblée nationale devra trouver la
juste équation politique pour faire
voter l'ensemble le texte par les
députés
on vous l'avez compris c'est un soir on
a particulièrement besoin de nos experts
Stéphanie Villers bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes conseiller à économique chez PwC
France Bruno palier bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi directeur de recherche du
CNRS au Centre d'études européennes de
Sciences Po puis hauteur de ce livre
réformé les retraites publiées justement
auprès de Sciences Po ouvrage qui
retrace entre autres l'historique de de
nos systèmes de retraite Bruno cotreize
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes politologue
chercheur au CNRS et eau c'est vipof et
Mathieu croissanto éditoris politique
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir bienvenue à vous
Stéphane Viller je commence avec vous
effectivement sur le le fond le contenu
de la réforme on l'a dit carrière longue
revalorisation des pensions minimales
on sait pas si c'est trop compliqué ou
si le gouvernement a menti aux Français
comment vous l'analysez vous
son revirement sur notamment les
carrières longues par exemple c'est pour
répondre à une contestation ou on a bien
vu dans l'opinion publique ça passait
mal c'est à dire ceux qui avaient
travaillé avant 20 ans trouver ça à
totalement inéquitable de devoir
travailler 40 trucs alors que d'autres
auraient travaillé 43 ans donc c'est 43
oui de 43 années donc c'est injuste un
réajustement et je pense que même avant
d'avoir proposé cette réforme ou c'était
un angle mort et il y avait pas ils
avaient pas ils avaient pas vu qu'il y
avait cette injustice sociale ou ben
c'était une marge de négociation pour
faire un pas vers l'opposition voilà moi
je l'entends comme ça
de confusions là depuis quelques heures
ou quelques jours est-ce que pour vous
ça remet en cause les bases même de la
réforme c'est-à-dire est-ce que c'est
parce qu'elle est mal née que on est
dans cette situation d'incompréhension
c'est surtout qu'elle est elle est née
sur un enjeu qui était censé être plus
simple on repousse l'âge de départ à la
retraite donc on joue sur les 64 donc on
n'est pas censé jouer sur les 43 c'est à
dire que si on choisit l'un une variable
plutôt que l'autre il y a forcément des
gens qui se retrouvent à travailler plus
longtemps que que les 43 ans et c'est un
peu là-dessus que c'est pris moi je
crois que c'est la conception de la
réforme qui n'a pas imaginé ça puisque
en gros elle a été portée par un souhait
de faire des économies budgétaires
rapidement et puis par le souhait de
piéger LR donc de reprendre leur
propositions qui est déposée d'être
traditionnellement au Sénat sauf que la
proposition de LR déposée au Sénat elle
n'est pas très sophistiquée il y a pas
d'étude d'impact etc et donc là ils
prennent les pieds dans les conséquences
des choses s'ils avaient pris un peu le
temps d'écouter à la fois les experts
les partenaires sociaux etc ils auraient
su que 64 ans pour tout le monde c'est
particulièrement injuste parce que ça
veut dire que certains vont travailler
plus longtemps et s'ils avaient pris un
peu le temps de négocier en amont pour
arriver à des positions partagées et pas
seulement faire des concessions au fil
de l'eau peut-être qu'il y aurait eu une
réaction un petit peu différente là ce
qu'on voit c'est que c'est des
concessions au fil de l'eau qui sont
malgré ce que dit Olivier Véran
improvisés il y a pas de d'études
d'impact qui soit faite systématiquement
donc on voit les parlementaires leur
demander mais combien de personnes
combien de personnes et ça il faut faire
tourner les machines pour le savoir ça
prend des ministres en difficulté qui
ont pas forcément les réponses tout de
suite on l'a bien vu et plusieurs fois
et notamment même avec les plus
techniques d'entre eux ce qu'on
supposait maîtriser parfaitement la
réforme Bruno cotress ce manque de
lisibilité ça a forcément des
conséquences dans l'opinion publique
française comment vous l'évaluez ça les
dernières enquêtes de pignon demandaient
aux Français comment ils percevait cette
réforme sur plusieurs critères au fond
la réponse est assez simple elle est
perçue comme d'abord injuste ensuite
comme pas clair et sans doute pas
efficace pas clair c'était déjà avant la
séquence de ces dernières semaines à peu
près ils disent c'est pas clair on
comprend rien effectivement c'est mal
expliqué
et puis aussi l'idée que malgré tout ça
sera quand même
elle aboutira quand même les trois
quarts des Français qui dans les
enquêtes de pions aujourd'hui disent
elle va quand même être votée
l'exécutifiera jusqu'au bout et sans
doute ça explique une partie de
l'opposition à cette à cette réforme
elle va le sentiment qu'on peut pas
échapper à une machine riz que personne
n'explique très bien qui donne le
sentiment de ne pas être bien maîtrisé y
compris par ce qu'il amène qui veulent
la mettre en oeuvre et qu'il a et qui la
propose donc toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour une espèce de grand
malentendu et ce qu'il faut souhaiter
c'est que on ne découvrirait pas au
lendemain de cette réforme votée qu'elle
a des effets inattendus des effets
campés étaient anticipés effectivement
avec l'absence d'étude d'impact qui est
un problème assez régulier quand même
d'entre dans notre modèle politique dans
notre modèle de l'action de l'action
publique et donc c'est un petit peu tout
ça il se trouve que là il s'agit de
quelque chose de fondamental pour tout
un chacun
la période de vie à laquelle on aboutit
après une vie au travail donc on peut
pas plaisanter sur des mauvaises
surprises qui peuvent attendre les gens
enfin voilà donc ce sentiment est
dominant dans l'opinion de quelque chose
qui n'est pas très bien ficelé qui n'est
pas très bien expliqué auquel on peut
pas échapper mais d'abord c'est un sujet
très technique la retraite je vous donne
un exemple traditionnel mais même sur la
la revalorisation des retraites
minimales pour les salariés ayant eu une
carrière complète autour du SMIC à 1200
euros on le dit comme ça maintenant pour
pas que les gens comprennent que ça
concerne tout le monde la CNAV par
exemple a beaucoup de mal à refaire les
carrières complètes des gens qui sont
déjà à la retraite et qui pourraient en
bénéficier elle est incapable de dire
comment comment elle va s'y prendre pour
le faire donc c'est déjà des suit et
puis c'est des sujets techniques c'est
vrai qu'il y a des leviers ça paraît
simple comme ça on dit un âge mais ça
des impact sur la vie des gens et la vie
des gens les jamais aussi simple que
dans les livres donc il y a des gens qui
ont des carrières linéaires qu'un
tableau Excel et après il y a un autre
souci c'est que ils ont fait une
concession qu'ils estiment dès le début
en passant de 65 à 64 ans contrairement
à ce que dit Emmanuel Macron qui lui
portait 65 et après toutes les
concessions qui font à la marge de la
mesure de la compagnement paraissent
soit j'allais dire futiles inutile
inefficace ou pas assez parce qu'en fait
les gens sont focalisés sur cette
affaire des 64 ans donc c'est c'est
perdant perdant et en plus c'est vrai
que d'un point de vue technique ça
paraît ni fait ni à faire la
présentation d'hier était catastrophique
il a fallu trois communiquer le Matignon
des tableaux pour expliquer qui était en
15 concernés on a cru un moment que
était concerné enfin les salariés qui
avaient 16 ans pourraient partir là on
parle des carrières donc ce 17 ne serait
pas concernés mais ce 18 sur les
confrères bref il y avait des trous dans
la raquette énorme et du coup quelle
lisibilité pour le message même les LR
pour qui c'est un cadeau n'ont rien
compris de ce cadeau là donc c'est quand
même on y reviendra sur la stratégie on
n'est pas sûr qu'elle soit beaucoup plus
lisible non plus mais je vais vous
redonner la parole tout de suite Bruno
palier mais démonstration finalement de
la difficulté pour un ministre en
l'occurrence celui qui porte cette
réforme le ministre du Travail Olivier
du socle qui est certainement pas le
moins technique sur ces sur ces dossiers
il était ce matin chez nos confrères de
France Inter et les journalistes
laissent et Nicolas demeure il s'est
passé déjà 20 minutes d'interview
auparavant ils font remonter les
interrogations des auditeurs écoutez
Zaga sur l'application permettez-moi de
vous dire que nous sommes perdus avec
votre réforme des retraites on avait
vous conscience Olivier
on ne comprend plus rien avez-vous
conscience de oui de vous avez dit on
fait de la pédagogie de la pédagogie de
la pédagogie et là on a des auditeurs
qui nous disent on comprend plus rien il
y a 42 régimes il y a des règles d'une
complexité extrême il y a une prise en
compte dans le calcul des retraites des
uns et des autres d'événements familiaux
d'événements personnels et chaque
réforme des retraites indépendant même
des mesures qu'on propose et presque
l'occasion pour beaucoup d'assurer de
découvrir ou de redécouvrir les règles
qui s'appliquent et c'est d'une
complexité parfois CAF Cayenne
c'est une complicité parfois CAF Cayenne
Bruno pallier si on compare cette
réforme avec d'autres réformes voter ou
non d'ailleurs est-ce qu'elle est aussi
complexe ou plus complexe ou au
contraire
le grand paradoxe c'est que cette
réforme était censé être hyper simple
par contraste avec la précédente qui n'a
pas été adoptée celle de 2019 qui visait
à simplifier le système et au bout d'un
moment ils ont jeté l'éponge en disant
c'est trop compliqué on y arrive pas
donc l'idée du gouvernement était
vraiment de dire on va faire un truc
simple c'est de 62 à 64 et
l'accélération des 43 ans donc dans le
dans le schéma c'est essentiel être très
simple peut-être qu'ils avaient oublié
ce que Monsieur duob viendra rappeler
c'est que de toute façon c'est très
compliqué et que même si on a des
mesures simples il vaut mieux peut-être
les préparer à l'avance mais je voudrais
revenir sur ce que vous disiez sur
concession concession c'est pas
construire un consensus ou c'est pas
construire un accord quand on compare
avec aussi bien des réformes qui sont
passées par exemple celle de 2003
Jean-Pierre Raffarin a attendu la sign
de la CFDT et des autres syndicats dit
réformistes avant de présenter la
réforme pour pour le vote ça veut dire
pardon nous interrompre il a laissé le
temps à la démocratie sociale de de
fonctionner ou pas oui oui on peut le
dire comme ça même si en fait il y avait
eu déjà la présentation des choses mais
il avait dit on va pas les fixer
complètement on attend de se mettre
d'accord il y a eu un accord ça a pas
étant complètement la conflictualité
sociale mais il reste que là il y avait
une base d'accord on pourrait dire un
peu la même chose pour pour
2008 par exemple en France on pourrait
surtout dire la même chose sur les pays
étrangers les pays étrangers ils ont des
systèmes relativement complexes pas
forcément aussi complexes que la France
mais le système allemand n'est pas non
plus simplificité extrême mais il y a le
souci de négociation et d'arriver à un
accord si ce n'est un consensus alors
ensuite c'est carrément un consensus que
l'on recherche donc tous les partis sont
d'accord mais on prend le temps non pas
de dire c'est comme ça et après je fais
des concessions mais le temps de dire
voilà que chacun
face face à pas et ça c'est la
démocratie qu'elle soit parlementaire la
Suède ou sociale en Allemagne c'est
beaucoup avec les partenaires sociaux ou
2003 en partie en France et on n'a pas
eu ça et faire des concessions
visiblement ça ne rapporte pas de points
politiques mais quand même je reprends
un peu vos arguments c'est vous parliez
d'angle mort tout à l'heure est-ce que
c'est pas l'eau d'une réforme des
retraites quoi c'est à dire que est-ce
que ce type de débat on peut pas l'avoir
à chaque réforme des retraites ou il y a
toujours un moment on va dire attendez
on a bien regardé ce que vous nous
proposez mais là ça fonctionne pas ce
que vous avez promis c'est finalement
pas réaliste moi ce que je pense
qu'effectivement nos systèmes de
retraite il est peut-être compliqué mais
toute notre système social d'aide
sociale et assez compliquée donc
globalement moi je trouve que les
Français sont plutôt habitués ils
découvrent pas qu'on a un système
compliqué et je suis assez admirative je
trouve au contraire que les Français
sont ultra rationnels parce que ils
viennent de comprendre que le système il
est assez basique on nous dit il y a pas
assez d'actifs pour payer des retraités
donc il faut rallonger le le la durée de
ils savent que de toute manière le
nombre d'actifs ne va pas augmenter on
sait très bien on connaît notre taux de
fécondité qui est en dessous des des
deux enfants par femme donc le problème
il date depuis les années 70
c'est-à-dire que depuis les années 70 on
a vraiment eu un taux de fécondité qui
baisse qui fait que les actifs et donc à
deux mois en moins actifs et financer
ils comprennent bien lorsqu'on leur dit
qu'il y a 1,7 actif pour un retraité
c'est une charge financière énorme sur
les actifs donc et je pense qu'en toute
logique il se disent on nous dit pas la
vérité c'est trop compliqué ça va pas
être si simple ils le savent que cette
réforme là cette première réforme n'est
pas va le début enfin les débuts non
parce que tu as eu d'autres c'est voilà
c'est la poursuite
Fatalis quoi de toute façon c'est très
fort ils veulent un éclairage ils
veulent qu'on leur parle vrai la
situation c'est que le système tel quel
alors on a décalé l'âge de la retraite
vous savez partout
en Europe on est à 65 ans 67 ans un peu
un peu partout pour autant là-bas le
taux de pauvreté des autres pays
européens des seniors et plus élevés que
le nôtre donc regardez donc on se dit
bah décaler l'âge de départ à la
retraite ça n'aide pas le système
puisqu'ils sont encore plus pauvres que
le taux de pauvreté donc il y a cette
logique et c'est incompréhension où les
Français réclament en fait la vérité ce
n'est pas uniquement rallongeant l'âge
que on va résoudre la problématique de
notre système de retraite par
répartition sur le long terme je reste
sur cette idée d'angle mort de la
réforme je j'essaye de voilà j'emploie
des termes on va dire sympathique
d'angle mort de la réforme qui sont
autant d'angle d'attaque pour les
oppositions c'est aussi ce qui fragilise
le gouvernement et sa capacité à
convaincre oui sa capacité à convaincre
est quasiment aujourd'hui mise à zéro
voir en négatif on ne voit plus du tout
dans l'opinion alors il y a quelques
petites évolutions les seniors
reviennent un petit peu aujourd'hui un
peu plus favorables à la réforme des
retraites mais on ne voit plus
aujourd'hui où sont les marges de
progression pour le gouvernement pour
convaincre parce que le prisme
aujourd'hui le filtre de perception est
tellement important sur c'est injustes
c'est pas clair et en plus ça ne
marchera pas parce que effectivement je
vous rejoins je pense que beaucoup de
personnes anticipent déjà contenu des
données que vous avez rappelé que de
toute façon
voilà les gens sont déjà sur l'idée que
de toute façon ça continuera et donc
c'est pour ça aussi que dans le pignon
il y a l'idée de dire mais il faut
réfléchir peut-être à des alternatives
puisque de toute façon on en sortira pas
c'est n'a pas la dernière réforme qui va
dansant dans ce sens là ce n'est pas la
réforme ultime donc ils anticipent déjà
ils réfléchissent à des solutions qui
sont alternatives et c'est vrai qu'un
des gros angle morts de la part de du
gouvernement a été de ne pas poser alors
peut-être échaudé par 2019 de ne pas
peser sur la table les variables
précédentes avant de parler des
retraites de parler des raisons pour
lesquelles les gens s'inquiète des
retraites qui sont pas seulement les
questions de financement mais qui sont
les questions de combien on gagne tout
au long de sa vie ce qui est une autre
manière de parler de combien on va avoir
au moment de sa retraite de parler de la
question de la formation professionnelle
travailler plus longtemps à quoi ça sert
est-ce que c'est pour rester sur un
poste de travail où tout le monde attend
que vous partiez on y va le vieux à
partir dans un petit moment où est-ce
que c'est pour avoir des opportunités de
se former voilà tout un tas de variables
qui n'ont pas été clairement pesées et
donc ça donne le sentiment à la fois de
quelque chose qui est pas clair qui est
pas juste qui ne règle pas le problème
oui alors on l'a déjà dit sur le plateau
mais je trouve que ça c'est quand même à
chaque fois essentiel de le rappeler
je trouve que
si on dit le gouvernement a fait les
choses à l'envers la question de notre
rapport au travail au sens du travail
c'est peut-être ça ce qu'il fallait
poser sur la table prioritairement c'est
clairement ça qu'il fallait poser sur la
table d'abord surtout que c'est très
forme c'est moins une réforme des
retraites que une réforme qui demande de
travailler plus longtemps puisque le
niveau des retraites va pas être changé
il y a rien qui les concerne et donc la
résistance à comprendre avant même de
savoir on n'est pas sûr que ça marchait
etc c'est pourquoi un certain nombre de
Français disent je ne veux pas
travailler plus longtemps et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment prendre le temps et
puisqu'on a le temps de revenir sur
cette question là d'abord rappeler que
entre 60 et 65 ans vous n'avez plus
qu'un tiers de français qui sont en
travail rémunérés donc quand on leur dit
il faut travailler plus longtemps il y a
une partie des gens qui disent mais de
quoi vous me parlez moi j'aimerais bien
travailler plus longtemps mais
j'aimerais bien je sais pas en tout cas
moi j'ai déjà été mis dehors et il est
clair que 58 60 62 ans ça va être
difficile de retrouver du travail en
tout cas en France dans dans les
circonstances passées comme comme
présent et puis il y a ceux qui sont en
emploi et ceux qui en emploient ils
manifestent à la fois physiologiquement
et dans les sondages d'opinion qui sont
à pour beaucoup d'entre eux
je dis physiologiquement c'est toutes
les enquêtes de sur l'augmentation des
troubles musculo-squelettiques sur le
stress au travail donne des indicateurs
particulièrement élevés pour la France
par rapport à d'autres à d'autres pays
et puis c'est aussi les enquêtes
subjectives qui disent moi j'en ai assez
je crois qu'il faut juste se demander
pourquoi on en est là et bien il y a je
crois deux raisons la première c'est que
on a concentré le travail sur un nombre
relativement réduit de gens c'est à dire
que les jeunes ils mettent du temps
avant de rentrer les seniors on les a
mis dehors il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont externalisés qui sont dehors et
donc on a concentré le travail dans les
secteurs productifs on leur a demandé
beaucoup beaucoup et on leur a demandé
de façon Top Down avec des chefs qui
disent voilà les objectifs et puis
puisque vous les avez atteints il va
falloir en faire encore plus la
prochaine fois un sentiment de
dépossession de son travail de définir
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et en plus de
c'est impossible à atteindre et ça c'est
à tous les niveaux de la hiérarchie
c'est pas seulement le salarié lambda
c'est le cadre aussi le manager aussi il
se dit mais on demande d'en faire
toujours plus quand on est en emploi et
puis il y a ceux mais est-ce que c'est
toujours vrai alors qu'il y a quand même
une grande majorité de d'entreprises qui
disent on arrive par recruter métier on
se bat pour fidéliser nos salariés ou si
c'est un peu la même chose on arrive
c'est un peu ça se rejoint parce que les
secteurs dans lesquels on n'arrive pas à
reconnaître c'est des secteurs ou les
personnes considèrent que les conditions
de travail ne sont pas favorables que
justement c'est particulièrement tendus
oui mais on peut aussi considérer que
pour fidéliser les salariés il faut
améliorer les dites conditions de
travail
depuis 40 ans mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
depuis 40 ans en France on lutte contre
le coût du travail donc en fait depuis
40 ans les politiques économiques visent
à faire baisser le coût du travail les
exonérations et puis les stratégies des
entreprises disent à réduire le coût du
travail on sait pas demandé comment on
fait pour avoir positivement une
productivité comment on fait pour
mobiliser et faire participer les
salariés comment on change de mode de
management c'est assez qu'on va parler
de la stratégie des LLR on va faire un
peu de politique juste dans un instant
mais je vois que vous vouliez réagir
Stéphanie dans une dans un espace temps
où Emmanuel Macron vise d'ici 2027 le
plein emploi qui est en en fait un taux
de chômage à 5% il va falloir
véritablement qui est des solutions pour
trouver un emploi au Seigneur parce que
effectivement comme vous disiez en fin
de carrière les seniors ont tendance à
être maître à être mis de côté ou mis au
chômage donc il va falloir trouver des
solutions pour pour les garder en emploi
et en fait là où je trouve que il y a
aussi sama elle était réfléchie comme je
pense que effectivement obligé les
seniors à conserver un temps plein
alors que il y a cette fatigue le
chômage inclut enfin mais n'inclut pas
le temps partiel donc je pense que s'il
veut Macron veut véritablement arriver
vers
un taux de chômage à l'équilibre
c'est-à-dire à 5%, un plein emploi et
bien il devrait explorer la piste du
temps partiel pour les seniors toujours
la même chose parce que on voit par
exemple que il y a 5% des retraités ils
sont en emploi donc c'est très peu pour
autant c'est ces personnes là sont à 70%
ou temps partiel donc en fait il y a
quand même une les seniors veulent
encore conserver un pied dans
l'entreprise on va pas passer
directement de l'activité à l'inactivité
et il y a quand même cette solution à
explorer qui pour l'instant mis de côté
allez on va parler de la stratégie LR
comme promis alors à première vue c'est
simple réuni en bureau politique hier
ils ont choisi de soutenir la réforme
comme nous l'a expliqué Bruno Retailleau
il y a eu quelques abstentions mais à la
quasi unanimité moins ses abstentions à
voter la mention que erikiotti nous a
soumis et qui est une notion qui accepte
bien sûr et favorable au report de l'âge
à 64 ans et au 43 amis de cotisations
voilà Bruno retaille au président du
groupe LR au Sénat mais c'était trop
simple évidemment puisque les LR à
l'Assemblée ont voté contre l'article 2
qui instauré cette index senior pour
inciter les entreprises à garder leurs
salariés les plus âgés bon on va avoir
besoin de deux chroniques pour essayer
d'y voir plus clair Matthieu je commence
avec vous
faudra quand même qu'un jour on se
repasse le film pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui était arrivé au
Républicain comment se parti qui propose
depuis 20 ans 30 ans des purges dans les
comptes publics des purges dans les
comptes sociaux ce parti qui peste
depuis des années de voir les Français
travailler pas assez à son goût dans la
semaine ou que ce soit tout au long de
leur carrière ce parti qui réclame à
longueur de programme et de convention
depuis 20 ans cette fois qu'on recule
l'âge de la retraite commence par qui a
pu se retrouver à la manœuvre pour vider
de sa substance une telle réforme je dis
une telle réforme parce qu'elle
ressemblait comme deux gouttes d'eau
vous en parliez pour nos palier à celles
et qu'ils appelaient de leurs vœux par
un vote symbolique chaque année au Sénat
comment leur nouveau patron
ericsiotti lui qui défendait il y a
seulement deux mois deux mois dans une
élection interne le passage à la
retraite à 65 ans ou l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation à 45 ans c'était il
y a deux mois et puis en arriver à
négocier avec la première ministre pour
qu'elle l'adoucisse son texte histoire
de le faire avaler assez troupes et
comment après avoir stoppé avec Matignon
ceci on continuait à faire monter les
enchères comme des maquillons et la
première impression c'est que ça marche
puisqu'il y a encore on l'a dit ils
avaient de borne leur a concédé de
nouveaux gestes sur ses carrières là oui
ça marche mais quel prix à quel prix
d'abord pour notre système de retraite
personne ne dispose de chiffres exact
mais il y a une première estimation qui
a été faite par Raymond souby l'ancien
conseiller spécial de Nicolas Sarkozy
social pardon et il avait estimé que les
premières concessions LR avait déjà
remis un tiers
économie dégagée par la réforme et alors
les nouveaux gestes vont alourdir la
note mais hier soir personne n'était
capable de dire combien ni comment à
quel prix pour la crédibilité de leur
partie ensuite les LR ils sont pris au
piège de leur conviction géométrie
variable et vous le disiez Thomas ils
ont été contraints d'adopter hier matin
au bureau hier matin en bureau politique
une motion pour appeler la ligne et dire
qu'il soutiendront la réforme et le soir
même voter contre l'article 2 avec le RN
et la nups le tout sans parvenir pour
autant à faire taire les critiques en
interne et notamment à faire rentrer
dans le rang le trublion du Lot Aurélien
chapeau et un strike à l'envers
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer maintenant
pour elle ça va être très compliqué
parce qu'en quelques semaines ils sont
passés du statut de force politique à
celui de force d'appoint pour ne pas
dire de supplétif j'allais dire peu
fiable et retors en quelques semaines
encore ils ont abîmé peut-être même
sacrifier leur image de partie de
gouvernement et puis en quelques
semaines toujours ils ont exposé au
grand jour leurs divisions alors bon
courage bon courage au sénateur LR pour
tenter de rattraper cette mauvaise
mayonnaise lors de l'examen du texte au
Sénat merci Mathieu alors ça c'était
pour l'analyse on va dire très politique
je propose maintenant à Mathias de nous
rejoindre pour parler plus
spécifiquement de cette index senior
bonsoir Mathias bienvenue le
gouvernement espère le réintégrer oui
c'est en tout cas ce qui a répété
Olivier verre en porte-parole de
l'exécutif hier soir à l'issue de la
séance à l'Assemblée nationale ce midi
en sortie de conseils des ministres et
encore cet après-midi en séance de
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement au
Sénat écouter le
pendant des semaines on a entendu des
rangs de vos collègues des rendre la
nupes à l'Assemblée nationale nous dire
qu'il fallait en faire davantage pour
l'emploi des seniors et le moment venu
au moment de voter pour un dispositif
qui peut-être n'est pas parfait à leurs
yeux mais qui améliore considérablement
l'emploi des signaux dans notre pays ont
décidé de s'y opposer j'espère madame la
sédatrice que vous aurez l'occasion
bientôt de voter en faveur de cette
mesure pour revaloriser les petites
retraites pour les Français et vous
serez appuyé cette fois-ci sur le bouton
favorable je vous remercie pour le
gouvernement a-t-il des raisons
d'espérer difficile à dire de notoriété
que La droite majoritaire au Sénat est
favorable à la réforme des retraites
qu'elle veut sienne mais sur la question
du fameux index senior les avis sont
partagés les républicains ne sont pas
pour mais veulent aborder la question du
travail des seniors comme le précise
René Paul Savary sénateur de la Marne au
micro d'Aurélien Romano
il est pas suffisamment
coercitive pour les autres il les trouve
globalement
je ne suis pas convaincu que ce soit le
seul dispositif qui permettrait
davantage de développer l'emploi des
seniors en conséquence nous allons
réfléchir à notre position par rapport à
cela
du côté de l'Union centriste l'autre
force de la majorité sanatoriale c'est
plus clair on soutient la mesure et on
veut même la renforcer alors le
gouvernement ainsi sur le fait que
s'agit d'une mesure pour réduire les
inégalités on peut peut-être donc aller
chercher un soutien du côté de la gauche
et non Thomas cet après-midi en séance
aux questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement la gauche de l'hémicycle au
Palais du Luxembourg a répété qu'elle
combattrait également cette réforme
concernant l'index senior pour la
sénatrice socialiste des Landes Monique
Lubin chef de fil de son groupe sur les
retraites le combat est ailleurs nous
sommes sur une loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale dans une loi de
finances on ne peut parler que de
finances et donc nous savons
pertinemment que le gouvernement n'a pas
pu aller au-delà que cette histoire
d'index parce qu'il sait lui qu'il
normalement il ne peut pas rajouter
autre chose dans ce projet de loi que
des questions financières et il sait lui
qu'il y a un risque au niveau du Conseil
constitutionnel
réponse à partir du 2 mars évidemment
suivra ça de très près merci beaucoup
Mathias Bruno codresse est-ce que vous
êtes aussi critique que Mathieu LR est
en train de d'abîmer des cornets
peut-être même de sacrifier son image de
partie de gouvernement je serai
peut-être pas aussi loin bien que je
trouve que la chronique était
effectivement tout le temps révélé bien
toutes ces contradictions au fond les
républicains ont essayé de transformer
le plomb de la présidentielle en or un
moment donné ils en avaient la
possibilité avec un coup de billard à
trois bandes absolument exceptionnel
c'est-à-dire à moindre frais sur un
sujet sur lequel ils ont une image ils
ont une cohérence effectivement vous le
rappeliez ils ont toujours souhaité ce
type de mesure et il baigne à trois
bandes obliger l'exécutif à venir vers
leur position et d'une certaine manière
retrouver à la fois du crédit peut-être
dans leur propre électorat retrouver un
rôle en disant ben nous voilà on amène
des idées on a même des idées sur la
table permettant à rixie d'incarner lui
qui rentre en fonction d'un carnet autre
chose que le sécuritaire le régalien
donc donc là il y avait une opportunité
qui était tout à fait
fabuleuse pour pour eux de se sortir au
fond de l'ornière de l'élection
présidentielle ratée et puis c'est vrai
que là on a des éléments qui sont des
éléments qui vont un peu en sens on
revient un petit peu vers le plomb d'une
certaine manière on va un peu à
contre-courant on fait passer un message
qui est un message qui a plusieurs
lignes à l'intérieur du groupe
parlementaire peut-être à l'intérieur du
parti même sur ces sociétés avec
beaucoup de difficultés pour eux de
poser le curseur à un moment donné et de
franchir le pas qui et de dire
effectivement ça correspond à ce qu'on a
toujours souhaité ça nous permet de
mettre un pied dans la majorité
présidentielle parce que pour les
républicains il y a quand même toujours
toujours une situation quand même
difficile ils ont perdu beaucoup d'élus
à l'issue des élections législatives ils
n'ont toujours pas réglé la question de
l'incarnation de leur leadership pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle ils
sont toujours dans de grandes
difficultés quand même donc là ils sont
toujours un peu au milieu du gué
si on revient au fond Bruno pallier de
cette index senior certainement pas
suffisant certainement critiqua mais
c'était quand même un progrès pour
améliorer le taux d'emploi des plus de
55 ans comment vous l'analysez ça ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que on parle de
l'emploi des seniors depuis qu'on fait
des réformes des retraites et notamment
je me rappelle d'une citation fameuse du
premier rapport du corps du Conseil
d'orientation
de travailler jusqu'à l'âge de la
retraite donc ça soulignait le fait
qu'il y a des gens qui sont hors emploi
avant l'âge de la retraite donc il y a
un enjeu ici et la façon dont on a parlé
pendant longtemps en France c'était
plutôt de faire sortir des gens donc la
pénibilité ça explique pourquoi des gens
n'arrivent pas à faire leur carrière
complète donc on va se mettre d'accord
sur qui on fait partir pendant ce
temps-là on sait pas mis d'accord sur
qui on essaye de faire rester sur
maintenir les seniors en emploi et donc
on n'a pas eu beaucoup de réflexion ni
beaucoup d'actions pour essayer de
réduire la pénibilité pour former Bruno
en parler tout à l'heure formé les
seniors tout au long de la vie pour
améliorer les position de travail
l'avantage de l'index c'est que il
pointe le doigt excusez-moi tout le
monde fait un jeu de mot dessus donc je
le fais aussi il pointe le doigt sur le
problème qui est celui de l'employé
secteurs les moins dix ans les
entreprises moins 10 ans sont montrées
du doigt voilà c'est vraiment la
première étape alors on peut rappeler
que la Finlande a procédé ainsi une
première étape en disant il faut
maintenir les seniors en emploi mais
est-ce que l'index va effectivement
servir à mettre à l'index les
entreprises qui se débarrassent des
seniors mais est-ce que on va importer
des solutions aux entreprises aussi
c'est-à-dire de l'aide à la formation de
l'aide à l'amélioration des conditions
de travail de l'aide aussi à la
conciliation emploi retraite de du temps
partiel etc ces derniers est-ce qu'on va
avoir une action positive et c'est là
l'écran des entreprises les craintes
manifestées par le sénateur que vous
interviewez c'est de dire mais si c'est
uniquement pour nous punir ça n'est que
du coercitif et on a besoin d'aide aussi
pas seulement d'être financière il y a
besoin aussi d'une approche positive les
choses moi je suis marqué parce qu'il
s'est passé en Finlande dans les années
90 qu'on voulut présenter l'emploi des
seniors ils avaient un indicateur comme
cela mais ils avaient aussi l'idée que
les seniors c'est le trésor économique
de la Finlande c'est quand on voit l'âge
moyen des Français l'âge moyen des
actifs il s'approche de plus en plus des
cheveux gris de la seniorité donc il
faut les les séries les garder les
maintenir en emploi c'est pas un poids
pour l'instant l'idée c'est que c'est un
quoi et alors c'est exactement ce que
j'allais vous demander ça fait du bien
c'est une question de d'état des presque
de culture au sein des entreprises et ça
ça se change pas simplement avec avec un
index plus ou moins coercitif alors
c'est pas qu'une histoire de culture
c'est aussi une histoire de réalité
économique parce que les seniors sont
concurrence quand même entre eux
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut pas oublier que
celui qui arrive à la retraite coûte
plus cher que celui qui a 5 ans ou 10
ans de moins donc il y a une les
entreprises en fait font un espèce de
rapport entre finalement embaucher
quelqu'un de 50 ans qui sera capable de
faire exactement quand la même
productivité que quelqu'un de 60 bon
peut-être qu'il aura pas
[Musique]
cours et essayer de conserver ces
seigneurs qui vont arriver vers 64 ans
alors je vais citer le prix dans la
République lors du conseil des ministres
ce matin sur je reviens à la politique
on navigue de l'un à l'autre c'est ça
qui est intéressant sur ce cette
thématique voilà ce qui dit en conseil
des ministres Emmanuel Macron les
oppositions sont perdus la vie des
Français et leur décor leur seul
boussole ce sont les élections ceux qui
nous ont demandé d'agir pour le chômage
des seniors se sont empressés de voter
avec le RN pour supprimer la mesure
dédiée est-ce que est-ce que ça ça
imprime dans l'opinion ça rejoint les
contradictions de l'air dans par la
Matthieu ou pas pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup pas beaucoup sinon on verra un
exécutif qui au contraire aurait pu
bénéficier de cette séquence Emmanuel
Macron
cherche à aussi ressusciter l'image de
Macron le réformiste lui qui a été le
gestionnaire de crise pendant nombreuses
années ils cherchent à ressusciter cette
image de réformisme et il en popularité
qui est en eau à cette tiède en ce
moment voire un peu un peu un peu plus
froide même il est lui et la première
min à son tour de entre 25 et 30% de
socle de popularité ce qui n'est pas
beaucoup pour conduire une telle réforme
aussi donc pour le moment les ressorts
dans le pion publique pour que Emmanuel
Macron sorte regaillardi de cette
séquence ne sont pas clairement là
dernier chapitre dans ce débat la
stratégie de la nuque et des syndicats
alors première question comment faire
pour que l'article 7 qui porte sur le
recul de l'âge légal soit examiné avant
vendredi minuit à l'Assemblée nationale
écouter Cyrielle châtelain député
europécologie les Verts 2 l'Isère hier
juste quand son groupe a annoncé avoir
retiré sans au moins 150 avant de Mens
supplémentaires on l'écoute
on va tout faire pour que le débat
avance voilà notre objectif c'est ça il
faut que le débat avance il faut qu'on
discute du report de l'âge légal à 64
ans il faut qu'on ait des débats de
fonds et il faut qu'on aille sur
aujourd'hui démonter les éléments de
langage du gouvernement non ce n'est pas
une réforme juste non ce n'est pas une
réforme qui se trouve oui c'est une
vraie forme c'est au détriment des
femmes oui c'est une réforme qui
pourrait être évité non elle ne va pas
sauver le système des retraites c'est ce
débat là qu'on va avoir dans l'hémicycle
Bruno palier la stratégie on va dire des
20 000 amendements de la nup elle ne
plaît pas la CGT on a entendu Philippe
Martinez à la CFDT qui veulent que voilà
il y a un débat parlementaire sur les 64
ans c'est c'est la réalité du mouvement
aussi aujourd'hui tout à fait c'est là
dessus que les syndicats sont unis c'est
sur le rejet du 64 ans et il faut bien
voir que c'est tout à fait exceptionnel
que sur une réforme des retraites on est
tous les syndicaps puisqu'il y en a pas
eu une seule précédemment où il y a eu
ce front syndical uni mais il n'est uni
que sur ce mot d'ordre là ils sont pas
abordés ils ne souhaitent pas aborder
les autres points donc c'est clair que
c'est là-dessus qu'il souhaite se
positionner et qu'il souhaite quelque
part demander au parlementaire et au
sénateur de prendre leur responsabilité
par rapport à leur point E il y a aussi
le jeu de contraste d'essayer de mettre
en avant la façon dont le les
manifestations sont calmes bien
organisées clair dans la revendication
c'est retrait du 64 ans par rapport à
confusions de communication comme ou à
la violence verbale de certains débat à
l'Assemblée nationale des débats
l'assemblée c'est clair que ça crée du
ciment pour l'unité syndicale qui joue
probablement de façon favorable pour
pour soutenir le mouvement soutenir le
retrait mais qui porte vraiment sur les
64 ans Matthieu il y avait une rencontre
qui était prévue aujourd'hui entre les
dirigeants de la nuque et certains
syndicats elle a été annonlé annulée
reporté on sait pas trop parce que
c'est dire bon bah ça avait fuité dans
la presse donc c'est parce qu'on
souhaitait etc il y avait pas tout le
monde autour de la table de toute façon
pour le coup c'est un vrai hiatus parce
que les syndicats c'est vrai on fait ce
de ces 64 ans le mot d'ordre leur seul
slogan il ne comprennent pas l'attitude
d'une partie de laupette faut dire que
c'est une partie c'est essentiellement
la France insoumise même si à la France
insoumise il y a aussi des sensibilités
différentes parce que la France
insoumise au fond ne veut absolument pas
ne voulait pas qu'on discute ni même
qu'on vote l'article 7 encore moins
d'abord parce qu'ils ont peur
d'enregistrer une défaite sur ce vote
ensuite parce qu'ils ont peur que si ils
enregistre une défaite ça démobilise les
manifestants et l'opposition c'est que
dans l'opinion une partie de Français
ont déjà acté une forme de résignation
en disant cette réforme sera de toute
façon votée et appliquée c'est à peu
près deux tiers des Français selon les
instituts et parce que la la la la nups
ne voulait voulait en plus que le
gouvernement incarne le passage en force
regardez on fait ses 64 ans alors qu'on
voit même pas eu le temps d'en discuter
à parler le problème c'est que les
syndicats n'entourent pas de cette
oreille et que des partenaires de la
dupesse les socialistes les écologistes
se disent c'est absurde c'est ridicule
et on va pas juste faire durer le
déplaisir avec des amendements qu'on
aucun sens juste pour éviter de parler
de ce sujet qui parle à tous les
Français et là la ligne de fracture est
en train de de se creuser on a vu
l'abandon de plus de d'un millier
d'amendements lundi soir là chaque
groupe essaie de faire de faire avancer
et les syndicalistes sont donné la voir
Laurent Berger criait comme un beau
diable depuis une semaine en disant
c'est le bazar l'assemblée il faut
absolument qu'on discute d'article 7
Philippe Martinez a donné la voix ce
week-end ça c'est nouveau en disant il
faut discuter l'article 7 au disputer de
prendre le responsabilités donc ils sont
pas en odeur de santé et puis on sait
par ailleurs que entre nups et en tout
cas entre la France insoumise et les
syndicats notamment la CGT ça va pas
toujours très fort il y a un mot qu'on
n'a pas prononcé dans ce débat peut-être
qu'il est tabou c'est le mot
capitalisation Stéphanie Villers est-ce
que finalement tout cette confusion
générale c'est pas une publicité
ça marchait comme sur des roulettes et
puis après maintenant on est en train de
gérer le Peppy boom là c'est beaucoup
plus contraignant donc voilà il y a pas
de ou autrement il y a effectivement
aussi l'issue de l'immigration mais je
pense que là aussi ça ça soulève
d'autres problèmes plus politiques donc
je pense qu'il faut vraiment la
complémentarité il est beau notre
système paraît partition c'est une
solidarité interne générationnelle on
n'a pas besoin il faut le conserver mais
il faut le il faut qu'il soit complété
par un système par capitalisation votre
avis là-dessus Bruno c'est pas cette
réforme là qui est de la pub pour la
capitalisation c'est chaque réforme
précédente en fait qui a annoncé que les
taux de remplacement les baissé puisque
je disais cette réforme n'annonce pas
une baisse du montant des retraites en
revanche celle de 2003 celle de 2010
est-ce qu'on peut faire autrement oui on
peut faire autrement si les Français
comme ils le disent dans les sondages
sont prêts à payer de plus en plus de
cotisations sociales et quand on demande
aux Français sans forcément leur poser
toutes les conséquences que ça ils
répondent plutôt oui plutôt que de voir
les retraites baisser et d'une d'un
regard comparatif pour l'instant la
place n'est pas encore faite c'est à
dire qu'il y a d'autres réformes en
Allemagne par exemple qui ont vraiment
fait de la place pour la capitalisation
puisque les taux de remplacement ont
fortement baissé on voit la
capitalisation être là pour compenser
c'était sans doute l'esprit de certains
réformateurs français des retraites on
peut penser à François Fillon par
exemple conseillé par par bébé par
accent là pour l'instant on n'en est pas
là c'est à dire que les calculs font que
pour un certain nombre de salaires le
système en place normalement permet de
maintenir à peu près son niveau de vie
donc est-ce que c'est complètement
nécessaire à inéluctable pas sûr pour la
France il y a des forces qui le
souhaiteraient effectivement merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat Bruno palier je
rappelle le titre de votre livre
réformer les retraites livre qui est
donc publié au presse de sciences